i mean i should probably mention
there's a non-trivial other branch where
we destroy ourselves right i mean
there's a lot of exponentially improving
technologies that could be
ferociously destructive um whether it's
in nanotechnology or
biotech and weaponized viruses
ai and other things that nuclear weapons
nuclear weapons of course the old school
technology yeah good old good old
nuclear weapons
that could uh could be devastating or
even existential
and new things yet to be invented so
that's a branch
that you know i i think is
is pretty significant and there are
those who think that one of the reasons
we haven't been contacted by
other civilizations right is that is
that
once you get to a certain level of
complexity and technology
there's just too many ways to go wrong
there's a lot of ways to blow yourself
up and people uh or i should say species
end up falling into
one of those traps the great filter the
great filter
i mean there's an optimistic view of
that if there is literally no
intelligent life out there in the
universe or at least in our galaxy
that means that we've passed at least
one of the great filters or some of the
great filters
right that we survived yeah no i think
ethics robin hansen has a good way of
maybe others they have a good way of
thinking about this that
if there are no other intelligence
creatures out there
and that we've been able to detect one
possibility is that there's a filter
ahead of us and when you get a little
more advanced maybe in a hundred or a
thousand or ten thousand years
things just get destroyed for some
reason yeah the other one is the great
filters behind us
that will be good is that most um
planets don't even evolve life or if
they don't evolve life they don't
involve intelligent life
maybe we've gotten past that and so now
maybe we're on the good side of the of
the great filter
you